Nobody knows what the self-driving cars of
the future will look like.
Once you no longer need a human in the
front seat operating a vehicle,
automakers can rethink every aspect of car
design.
Since the late 1960s, however,
the federal government has enforced detailed
safety standards
governing the physical makeup of the car.
Virtually every part of the car has had a
standard written about it.
There's about a hundred different subjects
that have been covered
both in advance notices and in actual standards.
The federal rule books, which have expanded
over the years,
have specifics on everything from rearview
mirror and steering wheel placement,
to the shape of the vehicle and the exact
placement of the seats.
Since self-driving cars don't need rearview
mirrors, steering wheels,
or even seats necessarily,
what should the federal government do with
it's roughly 900-pages of regulations?
I will make the contention that will rattle
the cage
of some people in the auto regulation business,
that basically the entire vehicle code can
be boiled down to
be safe, and do not unfairly get in the way
of other people.
Brad Templeton is an entrepreneur and software
architect,
who has worked as a consultant with Google
on its self-driving car project.
He says most regulation will become unnecessary
and detrimental
now that motor vehicles are becoming essentially
computers on wheels,
meaning software, not just hardware, is essential
for safety.
It's necessary to bring that tried, true,
trusted means of regulation to bear.
John Simpson works at the California-based
nonprofit Consumer Watchdog.
He says that the transition to driverless
cars
doesn't mean we don't need stringent safety
standards.
You don't say the algorithm will be written
this way, this way, this way and this way.
What you do is you set a standard that says
the vehicle shall be able to do X under Y
circumstance.
But the switch in emphasis from hardware to
software
could change the incentive structure in the
car industry
in ways that make government oversight less
necessary.
One difference is that when companies discover
a safety flaw
they'll have every reason to fix the problem
immediately.
With today's cars, that hasn't always been
the case.
Take a classic example,
General Motors found a flaw in the ignition
switches and they didn't do the right thing.
The American public were failed by a corporate
culture
that chose to conceal rather than disclose.
Replacing every ignition switch was very very
expensive
and so they were afraid of that cost.
But the safety problems of the future will
primarily be bugs in software not hardware,
so they'll be fixed by sending ones and zeros
over the internet
without the need to return hundreds of thousands
of vehicles to the manufacturer.
Replacing software is free, so there's no
reason to hold back on fixing something.
Another difference is that when hardware was
all that mattered for safety,
regulators could easily inspect a car and
determine if it met standards.
With software, scrutiny of this sort may be
impossible
because the leading self-driving car companies
are developing their platforms
through a process called machine learning.
Machine learning certainly doesn't mesh in
with traditional methods of regulation
or of software development, frankly.
With this method, the vehicle recognizes patterns
in its environment
and refines its own system through driving
experience.
But machine learning, which is a form of AI,
is developed organically,
so humans have limited understanding of how
the system actually works.
And that makes regulators nervous.
Templeton fears that our desire to understand
and control the underlying system
could lead governments to prohibit the use
of machine learning technologies.
It turns out that they do a better job, but
we don't know why,
we'll be in the situation of deliberately
deploying the thing that's worse
because we feel more comfortable that we understand
it.
John Simpson says extreme caution is warranted
because software in cars isn't like software
in other contexts.
It's one thing to test Gmail in beta mode
the glitches and you lose your messages and
you say
'oh hell's bells I lost my messages.'
and software that when it glitches actually
might kill you.
And I think that's an important distinction
to make.
That these need to be perfect before we allow them
on the roads
is a mindset that has infected a lot of urban
planners
and a lot of, just the general pro regulation
set.
Marc Scribner is a senior fellow at the free
market think tank
the Competitive Enterprise Institute.
He says that its this mindset that could cost
lives on the highway.
Delaying self driving car technology means
we are going to see additional deaths
that we could avoid if we simply would've allowed these
vehicles on the road
that are not perfectly safe but still safer
than the cars we have today.
The computerization of driving also has an
impact on how we build and maintain highways.
Some transportation planners say that to prepare
for self-driving cars
we need to construct smart infrastructure
that communicates directly with vehicles.
Templeton says that as driving become a software-based
industry,
the physical highways should mimic the internet.
So the internet, we like to call it the stupid
network
and that's 'cause the network is really really
simple.
When you talk about cars you talk about stupid
roads and smart cars.
You don't try and make the infrastructure
smart,
you make the infrastructure as basic as possible,
and you put the intelligence in the cars where
it's being built by lots of competing companies
and that's where you get the piece of innovation
that shook the world that the internet had.
If we need to install all of this new electronic
infrastructure on highways
and we're having problems filling potholes,
just from a pure budgetary and management
perspective, you're dreaming.
Physical infrastructure takes decades of planning
and implementation.
Templeton says self-driving cars provide an
opportunity
to make the roads quite a bit dumber than
they are today.
You take what infrastructure you do need to
have and you move it in the car.
An example is, the maps that google uses for
their car to drive
and they mapped all the roads so they don't
need anybody to paint new lines on the road.
They use that virtual infrastructure much
cheaper, much more flexible,
much more ability to change your mind about
what you want.
Auto safety technology, driven by the private
sector
is evolving much more rapidly than the federal
regulations.
And some of them, right now very clearly stand
in the way
of consumers adopting these safer technologies.
The more real danger is that the benefits
of this technology
will drive us to ignore the necessary safety
regulations right now.
the impact that computers will have on society
is really really big here.
You need a world where people are free to
come up with new innovations
that everyone else thinks they're crazy.